among other projects and you were doing
lots of stuff you get involved in some
very heady questions about the origins
of truth on the Internet and this is
where we're getting folks because the
the work that Danny is describing now in
theory ultimately became a venture right
metaweb don't so so that's right so what
I really thought is that what we need to
do is have a way of representing the
knowledge of the world in a way that
machines can get out them and take
advantage of it and that that should be
shared everybody should be able to get
at it that's in some sense that if the
nonhuman knowledge isn't a shared
resource then what is I think what what
if civilization been doing all these
years so it created a company that built
this database called freebase was free
database the and the company basically
took any kind of public knowledge that
we can get information about anything
and put it in a machine readable format
we were kind of creating it with the
idea that this is gonna be useful to the
world we didn't really have a business
model and we started building it up and
then it became useful to lots of
different people including in particular
all the search engines so eventually
Google bought it of course and then I
got Google to agree to keep it open for
three years but they only kept the part
that was already open open and they
started building it up and so now if
there's all the Google has something
called the knowledge graph which is
beyond the evolution of this and it
probably has about a hundred billion
different entities so everybody in this
room is in that graph the building this
building is in that graph yeah I took a
screenshot or
when you're just Google know your house
and all of these different yeah this
event is and yeah so so anything like a
person a place in the vend anything like
that is in this huge knowledge base and
they're all the relationships between
them are so when you for instance print
out a Google Mail that is rendered from
the knowledge graph so the knowledge
graph knows the bus schedules and it
knows you know the address the
restaurant and the traffic slowing all
this information together around the
thing that these searcher cares about
that's right so the map is just in some
sense a custom rendering of a piece of
the knowledge graph for your particular
purpose yeah and also by the way I don't
know the this doesn't have any ads on it
but the other thing is that the ads are
also a lot a lot of knowledge graph
about what the products are about and
you know whether you know it probably
has knowledge about you specifically and
so on so it's going to be way beyond the
kind of public knowledge it's also
beginning to probably have very
particular private knowledge about
people too now from Google's perspective
it's safe to say that this is a quantum
leap in terms of the original basis of
it's sort of citation based search you
know model all of a sudden it is now
providing this multi-dimensional search
that is drawing in way more richness
yeah so that it still does the old kind
of search so right now when you let's
say I put in museums of New York yeah
museums in New York well it still does
the old keyword search of searching for
pages that have the word museum and the
phrase New York but it doesn't if you
say
an exhibition in Manhattan or something
but you might have something as a museum
in New York that actually didn't use the
word Museum in New York on the page but
the knowledge graph knows that Manhattan
is in New York and it knows that you
know exhibitions are in museums or may
know something is a museum even if it
doesn't use the word museum and its
title and so it's actually able to pick
that up even though it's not it doesn't
have the keyword so that will play into
the search results to come up it does a
search that's based on the semantics and
of course that's very important because
that kind of knowledge is completely
language independent too so the same
knowledge that informs your search in
English also inform somebody's search in
Mandarin and/or Hindi something like
that so but the bad news is so the good
news is you know it's turned out to be
really useful there are these big
representations of knowledge but the bad
news is the whole idea that being this
free open thing that everybody was going
to use has actually become really just
something that is a competitive
advantage of Google and now you know
other other search engines and other
companies will make their own I'm sure
apples working on it
Amazon and you know every each of the
big companies IBM Microsoft you know
they'll each work on their own database
of I think so the world could go in one
of two directions we could either have
this serve oligarchy of big companies
that have been you know knowledge bases
that they use for proprietary advantage
or it could flip over and say it becomes
a public resource that we could say we
want knowledge to be a public resource
and we want in particular knowledge
that's tied to who said what is this dog
doesn't real reason truth remember
since who said stop and that becomes
then a resource for doing things like
sorting out what's big news or deciding
what medical treatments yeah you know
what what effects are in the scientific
literature
you know things things like that that
really don't align very well with
commercial right and this is where under
leg comes in underlay in many respects
is your attempt to kind of reclaim this
technology for the as the public good
that you can initially envisioned it as
yeah it's it's my penance for having
well so I've actually stuck on the
screen here I thought there was a very
nice paragraph on the very simple
underlay website which basically in
written terms explains kind of what what
it's attempting to do and it says the
underlay aggregates statements and
reported observations along with
citations of who made them and who
published them for example it would not
contain the bearer assertion that
Sudan's population was 39 million in
2008 but rather that Sudan's population
was provisionally 39 million in 2008
according to the UN statistics division
in 2011 referencing students national
census as reported by its Central Bureau
of Statistics and as contested by the
southern People's Liberation Movement
yeah and and it would do that in not in
those words but in a kind of machine
readable right so that those could be
and ultimately this is this version of
of what you were going at becomes almost
a kind of record of all of these
observations over time and it can be
tracked you know so if we wanted to get
to the heart of let's say you know
whether you know in one of these
hearings we've just watched somebody
said what are the other we could trace
it potentially back to the first
recorded instance yeah and and if you
take a problem like that I would regard
that as an apple
occasion of the under light just like
Google Maps as a drawing a map is but if
you take sorting through fake news and
recognizing when rumors are getting in
on control in order to do that you
really need a very complex
representation of who's saying what so
you're from kind of trace well this
person said batter this person said that
this person said that or you know the
New York Times said that you know the
Drudge Report said that you know and so
there is something that needs to be
built on top of of the underlay that is
essentially a network of trust for that
purpose so you know somebody has to say
well okay I trust New York Times where
that trust Fox News or vice versa or you
know I and these would be organizations
or individuals with some sort of
framework of analysis that could that
would that would leverage the underlay
and for interpretive purposes and
there's gonna be for different purposes
I mean and you know the awful lot of the
things that people argue about I mean
you know is Taiwan a Province of China
well you know if you're doing something
with the Chinese government you've got
account of this one if you're doing
something with Taiwan you're probably
not gonna commit you know so for some
purposes it is for some purposes it
isn't and and so there is what's the
truth of that well there is an exactly
the truth it's you know what's the
purpose what's the trust in it and so on
and in many of these the so so I sort of
feel like the underlay is in some sense
is a piece of the plumbing that we need
to deal with the fact that the amount of
information has become overwhelming that
no human can hold it all in their heads
no nobody can be sort of familiar with
all the new sources or things like that
and then that lets us build these things
on top of it where computers help us be
smarter in sort of navigate
these networks of trust and and so
you're conceiving of this challenge this
is in the mid-early odds right and what
was the you know what was the first
Inklings of an approach that technology
could provide to addressing this and to
kind of capturing the the chain if you
will of custody of information so so the
idea was to build something that that
basically said what the agreed on what
the things you were talking about the
entities that you were talking about let
people make statements about the
relationships between them but then have
some provenance of who made those
statements so that instead of recording
that you know the glass is sitting on
the table you record Danny said the
glass is sitting on the table on
such-and-such a day and then then you
want you to have all that information
recorded then that lets you first of all
it lets you record the information
without worrying too much about whether
it's true it's true that I said that
right which is much easier to determine
than whether it's true that the glass is
actually on the table and but then it
also lets you apply basically your idea
of trust afterwards after you get more
information about Who I am or later you
find out I'm a liar or later you find
out the class with someplace else can
weigh those previous recordings against
ya so so it's sort of the idea is that
what we really need to do is we need to
separate up two things we need to
separate the record of what different
people said and who said it the
provenance of what was said and then
separately remember it separately have
in some sense a network of trust which
is going to be different for different
purposes ultimately there's lots of
kinds of knowledge that I think really
are fundamentally part of the public
common the public good and I hope that
those will end up in it and I think it's
not as complicated as copyright law
where you know you're you're taking the
expression of individual artists and
things like that a fact is a fact
it's not copyrightable truth you know
somebody videos out that you know the
you know the geographical location of
this building you know that's that's
just a truth nobody owns that and and
really it's - everybody's advantage to
show that
[Music]